In the context of data centers, let's
first talk about internet services.
An internet service is any type
of service that's accessible via
web interface.
>From checking current weather conditions
at weather.com to searching or
checking email via Google search and
mail services, to making online bank
transactions or flight reservations.
The common way in which
these services are used is
end users send web requests via web
browsers and then receive a response.
Most commonly, these types of services
are then composed into three components.
A presentation component that
interfaces with the end users,
it's typically responsible for static
content related to the web page layout.
A business logic component,
this is a component that integrates all
of the business-specific processing.
And this would be all of the dynamic,
user-specific content.
And then a component that deals with
all of the data storage and management,
typically in a database.
These components are commonly referred
to as the presentation, the business and
the database tiers.
Although these are separate components,
they are not always implemented as
separate processes running
on separate machines.
What makes sense will depend
on the service complexity,
the resource requirements,
expected loads.
And also in the underlying
technologies that are used.
For example, the Apache http web
server can be used to implement both
the presentation logic,
to serve static content,
and also, as part of the same process,
php modules for
php processing can be used to
generate the dynamic content.
There are in fact many open source as
well as proprietary solutions that
are available that offer technologies
for either one of these tiers.
To put these applications using
these kinds of tiers together,
there are various integrated software,
or rather middleware,
components that are used, that
provide commonly used functionality.
Messaging services, service
configuration and management, security,
accounting, some persistence guarantees,
recovery management, and many others.
One important point to make is that for
services that are organized as
multiple processes, the inter-process
communication between those processes
is carried out via some form of IPC,
such as RPC or RMI, or
from Java based architectures.
As well as, some use of optimizations
that are based on shared memory,
in case that different processes
are running from the same machine.
So these are some of the examples of the
interprocess communication mechanisms
that we already dis,
discussed in this course.
And these are relevant in the context
of real world deployments of
Internet services.